[Music]
okay movie I didn't send your opening
logo because there's only wanted it only
last 20 seconds but this opening title
shot last for fucking ever and this one
you burn the 90s when grunge ruled
must-see TV was a thing and no one gave
it about skin cancer skin that's guy
exists hey hey easy on the fluids pal
the rubber sheets are packed it fuller
seriously has a bedwetting problem then
why couldn't you leave one rubber sheet
out honey are you packed yet yes yes
behold the great and powerful recording
device thingy that will provide 80% of
this movie's plot also kevin has the
ability to perfectly rewind the tape to
the exact spot he wants every goddamn
time he uses this booking thing
Christmas order Kevin what is it with
you and Christmas trees why did I have
to go anywhere I know we have to make a
sequel and all but this family put Kevin
through some severe trauma just a year
ago and now they want to go through the
same machination All Things Considered
Kevin's handling this amazingly well the
new celebrity ding-dang-dong stay at the
world-renowned Plaza Hotel they couldn't
come up with a better fake game show
than ding-dang-dong since they're using
100,000 fortune hunt props why didn't
they just make it that Bonnie do you
know where the batteries for this
camcorder is yeah I put in the charger
okay the last time this happened it was
a storm that knocked the power up this
time it's Kevin's dad who was so
reckless with his plug behavior here
that I assume he's actively trying to
lose Kevin also why did he need to
unplug the splitter box at all he was
just disconnecting the camcorder battery
charger which is on the underside of
this obvious fire hazard why are Kevin
and Buzz singing in the same choir sure
they might both be enrolled in this
school but Kevin's in the third grade
and buzz is definitely in high school
this performance is allowed to continue
despite the conductor in the pianist
looking straight at buzz while he's
playing the prank why is the entire
audience laughing buses prank isn't even
that funny I'm not the audience wouldn't
even be able to see it buzz is on the
top row so this show should just knock
him off the risers but because we're
meant to believe that Kevin ruins
everything the entire choir is taken out
before her employment at Saint Gerard
school this music teacher clearly worked
at the prometheus school running away
from things Kevin do you have something
to say you look out sniffer trout
sniffing so how does nobody else in the
family here bus say this Kevin you walk
out of here you sleep on the third floor
yeah
Jesus Christ Polar's turned what used to
be an accidental urination into a
full-on fetish
you'd better not wreck my trip you
little sour puss your dad's paying good
money for it Oh want to spoil your fun
mr. cheapskate it's everyone in this
family asshole hang on let me run down a
list of characters yeah yes no
definitely yeah that guy oh absolutely
Jesus for sure she's not that bad okay
I've confirmed this exactly one non
asshole in this family fight my own
money I go on my own vacation well you
got your wish last year maybe you'll get
it again this year
listen Kevin's being a bit of a dick
here but Kate's literally displaying the
same passive aggressiveness as last year
despite knowing exactly how that all
worked out why are Kevin's parents the
only ones in this entire fucking house
that have an alarm
they're the motherfuckers that are
responsible for waking the whole family
up and with their track record they're
still designated for this role how come
all of us are sitting together just tell
me you were lucky to get on the same
plane what how is it even possible that
none of them are sitting next to each
other even by accident there's looking
14 of them reinforcing my theory that
Kevin's dad is actively trying to ditch
him Kevin's allowed to run behind the
entire family without anyone looking
back for him despite the events in the
last movie okay I realize this is the
early 90s and they didn't have the
sophistication that modern airports do
now but they do have a manifest right
now it's definitely a ticket and
therefore person missing from this
flight before bumped into this lady
I bored him but make sure he locates his
family before you leave it or just very
casually let him identify the back of a
random person that somewhat resembles
his father despite not seeing any of his
other family either way it works I'm
pretty high right now anyway we'll go
find an empty seat an empty seat it's
not in southwest lady have you ever been
to Florida was it ISA my Yin the Fosters
into it even though Kevin asked this
question in English this asshole starts
a soliloquy in French because I guess we
needed a reminder that all non-american
tourists are dumbasses
American Airlines don't turn wrong I
have that feeling are you telling me
that Kate didn't check once they got on
that plane that everyone was on also
there are so many fucking instances of
this movie just repeating the first one
that I'm gonna stop listing them
individually and instead just give the
movie 20 extra sins for being lazy this
radar indicates that Kevin's flight to
New York is 2 to 6 but the flight
attendant announced it as 176 which
Kevin didn't hear because he had
headphones on so I guess the person in
charge of continuity assumed we also
couldn't hear it and couldn't be
bothered with details like the correct
flight number that we specifically
mentioned three times all these adults
ignore the pleas from a child that's
obviously lost New York you know I
realize Kevin was mad at his family last
night when the whole fight with buzz
went down but he seemed genuinely fine
this morning in the Vale and even had a
few nice moments with his dad before he
was callously ditched so what's Kevin so
fucking excited about here besides the
fact that he gets to deliver the same
line again Jesus Christ movie I know
you're trying to cram in all the
interesting spots in New York City but
Kevin just went from Midtown to Chelsea
then walk from there down to Chinatown
which is all the way in lower Manhattan
then went to Battery Park at the
southernmost part of the island was
anyone paying attention to the practical
realities of this movie even though it's
the bustling a holiday season Kevin is
the only person allowed on the world
trade center observation deck why are
Harry and Marv in this fucking movie the
fact that it has to be the same
criminals as last year somehow makes it
even more stupid and this movie could
have taken advantage of this new setting
and giving Kevin someone else to go up
against where Dana Carvey and Jon Lovitz
busy Kevin is now operated all the way
up to Central Park because nothing means
anything and looking at an actual map if
you work on this movie and yes he could
be using taxis to get around but there's
not one to be seen after he rides in
from the airport I know I know the
movies got a movie but I'd be remiss if
I didn't at least mention how
astronomical the odds are that not only
Kevin and the Wet Bandits are in New
York City at the same time but the
they pass each other on the same street
down the hall and to the left also why
is Trump looking back at Kevin
in fact why is anyone looking at this
kit in New York some kid walking around
by himself wouldn't even be in the top
100 of weirdest things seen that day for
most of these people if you needed any
more proof that Kevin grows up to be
jigsaw and/or the collector here it is
hanging how long the McCallister's woke
up when the transport showed up at 8
a.m. which means there's no way they
made a flight before 8:45 just like the
last movie it's at least a two-hour
flight from Chicago to New York and New
York is on Eastern Time so the earliest
Kevin would land there would be 11:45
local time factoring the time he spent
looking around the airport and the cab
ride into the city and he gets to
Manhattan at 1:00 p.m. so he did all
that around the city which included a
trip to the top of the World Trade
Center in an hour and 45 minutes ceedric
yes don't count your tubes in public I
know I'm going hard at this movie and it
deserves it but I'm taking ass in off
for Tim Curry it was a national treasure
I don't care that he's English we're
claiming him this is one of our finest
sweets sir only the plazas gouging the
McCallister's Kevin only asked for an
extra-large bed TV and mini-fridge but
they up sold him doing sweet without
telling him it's as if whomever stalked
him any bar and what kid would be
staying in this room all by himself on
his dad's done do you know how the TV
works ten years old
TV's my life okay I know this movie was
released two years after the first one
but it wants us to believe this takes
place one year from the previous events
but in the first movie Kevin was 8 years
old now he's 10 did he take one of those
gap years that everyone talks about
isn't that how that works
[Music]
movie makes yet another lazy ass joke
about Kevin swimsuit coming off during
the Cannonball
despite clearly showing that it stayed
on after he hit the water hast keeping
mice Kevin freaked out he just had room
service in here so the hotel staff know
his dad isn't there yet but the was the
concierge his plan even if he's
suspicious of Kevin is its standard
practice to break in and head directly
to the bathroom to investigate good
thing Uncle Frank said nosy little
pervert instead of you know Kevin I was
gonna give this movie props for getting
the correct area code in New York for
uncle Rob but then I noticed that the
Millers and the meanors both have
letters in their phone numbers so props
are retracted and sins are rewarded
[Music]
unlike the last movie Kevin's mom is
a-okay with leaving the airport without
knowing Kevin's location or being
immediately available to jump on a
flight once he's found your drawers sir
Jesus this shows that Kevin's reaction
to the concierge is knock last night
makes even less sense he's sending his
underwear to be cleaned hey nice house I
can't figure out if Marv was supposed to
be funny dumb or just an asshole so
what's the plan
everybody leaves for a nice holiday off
we come out of our little houses you
chat and all but our Marvin Harry really
waiting until they're in this position
to discuss their plan for the robbery
also what happens if someone decides to
buy the Playhouse's they're hiding it
two turtledoves
you keep one and you give the other one
to a very special person or to a random
homeless lady that you'll meet later
tonight
and get to know for less than two hours
up to you she turtledoves irish symbol
of friendship and now the 1990s was the
last decade where this line being
delivered by an old dude to a kid
wouldn't be creepy
Wow Harry's vision comes with its own
zoom and enhance cliche look who it is
love
Harry's revenge boner is so strong he
doesn't even notice what a massive
coincidence this situation is look I
know this is New York and people don't
give it but seriously no one offers
assistance to this screaming child
that's being accosted by two
shabby-looking grown men ton of people
we're just walking in this area but
somehow hearing and Marv are the only
ones that can't avoid the pratfall Jesus
Christ did Harry have a cyborg retinal
transplant while he was in prison or
something hold it right there I don't
know what's more annoying the fact that
Kevin can perfectly edit this video on
the fly or the fact that I'm gonna have
to watch another repeated scene from the
last movie again also does anyone
remember how the sound was on VHS tapes
there's no way the staff thinks they're
talking to an actual human hear how the
can did Harry and Marv know Kevin was
coming out of this exit in the loading
dock especially given how moronic these
assholes are shown to be a city of
millions of people and they keep running
into the same people over and over one
of the most unexpectedly annoying things
about this movie is marbs constant
thievery of clothing without any
repercussions I want to go home just not
badly enough to talk to a police officer
or go to a hospital or really do
anything that would facilitate that New
York move it why is everyone going if
anything this makes it more difficult to
find Kevin if they have to keep up with
the entire family plus Kate just said
that it's almost impossible for everyone
to be on the same plane during the
holidays and now it's Christmas Eve New
York City is full of ugly crazy
dangerous people cliche this prostitute
is extremely comfortable with
propositioning a ten-year-old crazy
misunderstood bird lady stands up just
slowly enough to ensure Kevin's maximum
terror great not only is this sinful for
romanticizing New York City pigeons and
seriously those pigeons this is way too
much pigeon stuff in this story about a
runaway child being pursued by two
criminals how do you get to Carnegie
Hall
no not practice you clearly break into
its instrument loft late on Christmas
Eve I wasn't always like this you know I
had a job I had a home had a family but
the man I loved
fell out of love with me skip I'm just
afraid if I do trust I'm gonna get my
heart broken again that's your main
concern right now what about
histoplasmosis
I'd be much more afraid of that getting
pretty late I better get going
considering how long it feels like this
conversation has been going on I'm
guessing or at least three days past
Christmas
say goodbye to your birds for me or you
could do it you're standing right by
them
you can mess with the lighter things I
can't mess with kids on Christmas so if
this had been Easter Kevin would have
just said those kids and gone on his
merry way
also Kevin's headed straight to the
police right right damn it casual
Breaking and Entering is casual did
Kevin draw all this and then roll it
back up so you could have his own
dramatic blueprint roll out a few
seconds later also sure it's absurd that
Kevin put this entire plan together and
that he's planning to lure Harry and
Marv back to the house in order to
torture them but I'm more skeptical
about his ability to find a full set of
colored markers in this construction
zone he's in full view with the entire
Street which is the affluent and crowded
Upper West Side by the way but nobody
sees this future horror movie villain
going about his business here it's
Christmas Eve and because of you our
child is lost in one of the biggest
cities in the world um not to overstate
the obvious but this is some serious
blame shifting this is like saying the
drive-thru guy at Taco Bell made you fat
not to beat Kevin's geographical
abilities into the ground but how did he
know how to get from where he was to the
toy store last time he got here on a
limo from a completely different
location you know for an experienced
thief Harry is terrible at putting money
in a bag that should be the first thing
you learn at thief Academy actually
considering Kevin used to flash for the
shot he almost definitely took a picture
of his own reflection me the antics in
the first movie at least had some basis
in reality if they survive all this bull
Marvin Harry should be in the next Fast
& Furious movie I guess the alarm that
went off after Kevin through the brick
just decided it had enough and stopped
on its own holy
Kevin graduated from mildly harmful
pranks to outright attempted murder in
one year look I understand we're
supposed to laugh at all this carnage
and some of it's funny but asking me to
believe this mother wouldn't look down
and see the total lack of flooring is
more than a suspension of disbelief it
would take like an expulsion of
disbelief wow this solid concrete floor
just magically tilted so that Marc could
slide into this bookcase
how would Kevin have any clue how to do
this at least the first movie stuck too
ridiculous but fairly easily made
contraptions this movie makes Looney
Tunes look legit also of course I get
that this part of the movie isn't
supposed to be taken seriously however
the problem is the rest of the movie
wants to be taken seriously so this is
like trying to have your cake and
torture it to age criminal Harry not
only does a perfect handstand on the
toilet instead of just dunking his head
in there or simply taking off the cap
but he also holds the pose even after
the massive explosion last year does
anyone look I'm running out of ways to
say Kevin is clearly a fucking
psychopath
at this point eventually becoming a
member of a pizza based rock band is the
best-case scenario by far the two guys
don't destroy chests or in the puck even
though in the last 20 fucking minutes of
this movie have kept Marv and Harry in a
confined space Kevin waits until now to
call 911 and lead them to an open public
area
he got a gun yeah and what's up with
that Harry's had multiple times where
Kevin was just standing there in front
of him including before they went down
the road
so why the phazon he just shot him it
took nearly two full movies for Kevin to
finally be hoisted by his own petard do
you have kids yes ma'am and what would
you do if one of them was missing I
don't know maybe hang out in a Miami
hotel room watching It's a Wonderful
Life until a Rando airport security
officer found a clue Jesus lady lay off
your guilt trip until you can go a full
calendar year we're not losing a child
[Music]
I need to get to Rockefeller Center sure
Kate knows that the biggest Christmas
tree in the city is at Rockefeller
Center but how does Kevin know that and
how does she know that he knows there's
a possibility all I just seen my mother
Kevin's praying to this Christmas tree
instead of literally calling his mother
on the phone or reaching out to really
anyone in an authority position Jesus
Christ who keeps giving this kid all
these cans of coke before bed if this
sweets big enough to have to clean
floors why are all the kids sleeping on
top of each other yeah yeah magical
Christmas magic and shit but come the
hell on how in the world would Duncan be
able to track Kevin down to the plaza
figure out how many kids are there their
ages and then be able to mobilize this
amount of gifted considering what Kevin
just put his family through he could
have at least let them know what he was
doing
even in 1992 I'm calling bulletins on
that bill given how many pages buzz just
went through it would have been triple
that easily
sometimes it just means forget about
Plaza Hotel Reservations may help you
[Music]
hey you can do it
hey did you happen to see the most of
you to thrill shut it
I suddenly remembered my Shalini but my
armies be the rocks and the trees and
the birds in the sky
[Music]
except that a bird ran into my giant
freak head
I'm Kevin McCallister I'm kind of a big
deal